how are you what's up i'm good man how
you doing
good good to see you both this is very
exciting these are two of my favorite
characters in the mcu
and from what i've seen on screen and
even all the featurettes every interview
looks like you guys have the best time
how's your bromance going
are you are you stronger connected now
than you ever have been before the two
of you
we're still obviously not because
sebastian knows nothing about me
it's an evolving relationship like all
of the base
the best great hollywood marriages yeah
two people two people constantly
evolving
evolving anthony you said sebastian
knows nothing about you like he doesn't
know your favorite song
he doesn't know your favorite movie
nothing i don't want to
i don't want to bring it up i don't want
to harsh i don't want a heart on old
stuff
we're evolving we're moving
it's exciting to see uh your characters
get more time to explore who they are
what they're like what they're up to and
where they fit in this universe is that
something that is
super exciting for you to be able to
tell extended stories of these guys that
we kind of know from the films
anthony uh yeah i mean you know
it's been a a long time now that
i've been in the mcu to be able to flush
out the character and really introduce
him to an audience and
you know have people appreciate that and
now know who he is is great because the
falcon is a
amazingly written and developed
character in the
universe uh sebastian i don't want to
bring it up again but what's anthony's
favorite sandwich
he won't come to new orleans so he
wouldn't know that it's a shrimp po boy
dressed with extra pickles and hot sauce
i just know that anthony drinks his um
protein shakes with whole milk
all right and he's playing those real
man drinks
and then if it ain't bourbon on a friday
night then
you know it ain't working it's working
because i'm canadian i'm gonna fight fan
also i gotta ask you know gsp
is uh is featured in the series uh he
had a great scene and a great fight
scene like his introduction
in uh winter soldier in the film what's
it like
working with him and going toe-to-toe to
him in scenes in those action scenes
uh i have a great gsp story breaking
news on et canada
i took a full punch to the head
from gsp and took the punch and didn't
get knocked out
true story we have footage of it i also
have a story about jizz
[Laughter]
this is before we shot uh captain
america winter soldier i saw him in an
airport
and he was eating a pizza and and i and
i thought i'd go over there and just say
we were about to make a movie together
and
and i was like hey i'm so-and-so and he
was like yeah yeah
sounds good it didn't really go very
well
so is that something actually one of the
nicest
and i mean you know he's an incredible
uh fighter but he's such a nice he's
actually incredibly nice but
yeah at the time i don't think he really
knew yeah like
that i was actually telling the truth
you know
i think my story of getting punched in
the face by him
is much better than your story anthony
you have too many
stories of people accidentally punching
you i know
it happens a lot man it happens a lot i
get in a lot of fights
well people aren't going to mess with
you after this series that's that's for
sure
right we'll see you so much for the time
i'm so excited to finish this thing
looks so great thanks a lot man
appreciate it